foreign
let's go out to Minnesota and talk to
Kaylee what's up Kaylee
hello how are you so good how are you
I'm good can you hear me okay I can't I
can hear you great
what's up well my question is is
um kind of just how can I stop comparing
myself to others
um I feel like I've been doing that for
years and now I feel like I'm
specifically comparing myself to my
sister all the time
and also we have uh
kids who are three weeks apart and I
feel like I'm also comparing
person and my son because they're so
close in age like a person talks more
than my son does right now I'm like oh
my gosh my son is so behind and
so I was just kind of wondering your
thoughts on that and how I can stop
comparing my just my life to other
people
um it sounds simple like just stop doing
it but I don't know it's like my
thoughts just take over and I kind of
feel like I need to be doing more with
my life and things like that so
this often comes from a place
a home environment where somebody had to
do things in order to get love they had
to make perfect grades they had to
perform on a ball field they had to do
things so that
was that you
you know it it really wasn't but I will
say that I've heard you say
um say
so you kind of was always reflecting
back to my childhood and I grew up with
just my mom and my sister for the most
part it was just just us and my sister
was like straight A's never got in
trouble like just the typical
stereotypical first child and I was like
the complete opposite and my mom
literally like truly never once ever
compared us never once made me feel like
I need to be doing more
um but then I think about like my dad
and he just wasn't in the picture much
like at all and
um got remarried two months after
divorcing my mom and had twins and just
kind of started a new life there so I
don't know if it maybe stems from that
but two things one
we'd have to spend some time together
but I it would be such a rare situation
with what you described with your mom
okay that would be so rare it and I
would tell you this it's not worth
Mining and going down every rabbit hole
in your mind right yeah
I would be willing to bet
whether it's glances whether it is high
fives whether it is I'm just talking to
your sister right now that straight a
straight a sister
got the nod
the second thing is is yeah it very much
could be it's very real possibility that
there's a little girl in there wondering
what was it about me that dad left
right and I'm gonna keep my head on a
swivel and look for every place in the
world where I'm not the best or I'm not
the prettiest or I'm not the tallest I'm
not making the most money we're not the
smartest kid whatever the thing is
because I'm so paranoid about somebody
else that I care about leaving me and
I've gotta I've gotta achieve Perfection
to get there and of course you know it
doesn't exist it's not real
yeah right um I'm kind of getting a
little emotional right now I just sorry
no it's good you're good you're good
and so I just I just have a lot of
feelings like with my dad
just kind of leaving and just not really
being a dad have you ever talked to him
about it
I never have no
it might be worth that conversation do
you still have a relationship with him
yeah we do and he's like if I've ever
needed anything
like with money things like Daddy's
always held yeah
you needed something way more important
than money and he left
it's real easy to look at tangible
things like clothes in a car and and car
insurance and say he gave me everything
no he didn't man he left
yeah
you're not crazy he's just like super
involved in my half siblings lives and
it's just like he never taught me how to
drive or went to a softball game or went
to my prom and
so I think a lot of
like the comparison and things I guess
maybe stems from that I'm probably not
fully healed from that obviously I'm
crying right now but sure I guess I have
a lot of work to do from from that yeah
I
here's the thing about comparison
um
you have to heal that from the inside
out
and there's not going to be an external
thing that comes in and makes you feel
whole enough to not care how your sister
even more so not care how her her her
toddler's doing but to celebrate the
fact that he's really smart
yeah celebrate the fact that he knows 50
words and your kid Only Knows six
yeah and I really want to get to that
place I really really do so go there
with gratitude
okay
uh you've heard me say a lot on the show
about keeping a gratitude Journal write
five things at night that you that start
with the sentence I am grateful for and
just do that every night but I want you
to start a gratitude Journal where you
are intentionally grateful for the
success in other people's life
okay I'm so grateful that my sister is
so beautiful
yeah I'm so grateful that my that my
nephew is just crushing it
yeah it's a really good idea I should be
doing that and
I want you to spend some time
talking to my friend Kaylee in a
positive way
because it's not better or worse it's
just different you're gonna have a
different life you've always had a
different life from your sister right
right yeah exactly
she wore
high heels and you wore Converse and she
made Straight A's and you got dates
right I mean it's like y'all had
different lines right yeah yeah and the
thing is we're so different but like
we're so close like we hang out all the
time of course yeah we have a really
good relationship and she's never made
me feel either like I need to be doing
something more so I'm grateful for that
have you have you ever told her that you
feel like you uh live in a shadow
National
I never said that I think you should
okay
I think you should
yeah I think you should tell her I've
spent so much of of my life being
jealous of you because you're so
beautiful Your Kids smart this and this
and this yeah and I want you to know I'm
still working with I still wrestle with
that haunting question why dad left us
and I want you to know I love you and
I'm so proud of you as my sister
yeah well that's what you know I'm
struggling
okay that's a good idea and is that if
you didn't have a good relationship with
her I wouldn't say Don't just bomb her
with that right it sounds like y'all are
super close my promise is that she feels
that disconnection she feels that Gap in
your relationship she doesn't know what
it is
yeah she just thinks it's crazy sister
Crazy Aunt Kaylee
better than me this and I don't know I
just
I don't know it's really tough and I
just feel like I need to be like
changing my thoughts around it it is
it's a hundred percent
and what I'm about to tell you to do is
so cheesy and it's so absurd sounding
and it's been magical in my life in
another's lives
but there's something about looking in
the mirror and balling your fist up your
hand up in a fist and put it in the
middle of your chest and looking in the
mirror and saying I love this girl
I love this guy
yeah
and then writing down I'm a good teacher
I'm a good mom
I'm a good fill in the blank and I'm
going to make that a repetitive thing
until those thoughts become part of my
life
okay okay
also you can't just think your way there
what does that mean I've had to come
face to face sometimes when I'm
struggling with comparison that that
person actually does work harder than me
they are smarter than me and some
sometimes I've had to up my game
yeah right sometimes my comparison has
been has been right
okay yeah yeah I can see that too but
also like uh my my buddy Lane Norton
he's ripped beyond measure
and he lifts like a like a forklift he
can pick up that much weight like a
house
and when I'm around him
dude talk about comparison
he's handsome he's really successful in
business he's a world champion I am not
those things I'm a YouTuber Kaylee you
know what I mean and I joke you're a
good YouTuber I go jogging right but
here's the thing I don't want that life
he has
like that's not I I I
love cheering from my friend
I don't I don't my my buddy who's an
attorney I love that he's so successful
I don't want the life of being a lawyer
yeah right so it's it's in celebration
it's in recognizing I feel myself
comparing and being like yeah he's a
world champion lifter right I'm not that
um or when I was a teacher like this
person's an incredible teacher and they
work at it too a lot I don't so I cannot
be a teacher I don't want this life or I
can work really hard at getting better
at it but all that comes back to that
comparison which is
I'm good
and you cannot get that peace
externally has to come from the inside
has to come from the inside out
and so I want you to spend like I said
spend some time in gratitude for the
success of other people I want you to
practice not staring at your own belly
button and looking up and out
and then I want you to take that same
posture and look in the mirror and look
at Kaylee and let her know that you love
that girl you love her
and
here's some things about her that I do
love
and here's some things we're going to
work on
let's practice that for 30 days 60 days
90 days and let's also bring your sister
into the vulnerability
struggle with this do you struggle with
anything from Dad I still struggle being
second to you I still struggle with why
he left do you have anything that haunts
you and she might say no you're crazy
she's probably not gonna say that
you're not gonna say that
you're a great sister Kaylee
your little one your son is is lucky to
have you your nephew's lucky to have
your sister's lucky to have you
Kaylee's looking to have Kaylee